I have to destroy Ben Shapiro with facts
and logic last week on his show he
talked about the UFO hearings on Capitol
Hill and he had exactly the same kind of
dismissive attitude you would expect and
it's the same attitude that everybody
here at DW has except me all of these
systems that would provide for the
surveillance they always go down just
like Bigfoot so many people have seen
Bigfoot and yet and yet nobody seems to
have gotten like a really credible good
view of Bigfoot that they can then show
there are a lot of credible images this
is not like Bigfoot at this point I'm
convinced that the people here
especially why would keep making this
big foot comparison they're doing it
just to attack me personally they're
doing it just to annoy me personally
because the comparison only proves why
the alien stories are more credible